nouvelle cité scolaire était une c'est
le premier chapitre de sa vie
ce 24 juin 1974 maurice genevoix est de
retour dans sa ville natale à 2,6 dans
la nièvre
il vient inaugurer la cité scolaire de
la commune qui porte toujours son nom
aujourd'hui l'enfant du pays qui a
pourtant vu bien pire est touché par
cette attention
maurice genevoix alors qu'il dévoilait
la plaque du nouveau centre scolaire
murmure est à sa femme de ses mots assez
inattendu venant de lui ne pleure pas où
je vais me mettre à chialer
c'est dans cette maison de l'avenue du
14 juillet que l'auteur est né le 29
novembre 1890 il y vivra un an avant de
rejoindre le loiret un court passage
qu'il n'a jamais renier qui l'a même
profondément marqué comme la cité
nivernaise et que l'on retrouve souvent
dans ses écrits il avait qu'une
empreinte et puis il n'a vécu que
quelques mois à deeside tu as un retrait
c'est aussi plus tard dans ses écrits
font ressentir par rapport au fleuve
donc la loire qui traversent notre ville
et on voit que c'était vraiment aussi le
fil conducteur de sa vie il écrivait
ainsi qu'il était né dans une île de la
loire pays de rohff l'aide images
fluides dans les librairies comme ici à
dijon ces ouvrages sont en bonne place
lui le prix goncourt 1925 mise au
programme des classes de 4e il reste
méconnu
je le vends régulièrement après je pense
que le fait qu'il va rentrer en 35 ans
ça va booster un peu les ventes mais
c'est vrai que ce 14e raboliot cd titre
que joint pas tous les jours mais au
moins une fois par mois avec son entrée
au panthéon
l'histoire de cette plume de la grande
guerre n'a donc pas fini de vivre